[Musique]
merci merci
alors petite question qui au collège
j'ai dû en collège
mais ce genre de portable vous levez la
main si c'est le cas le nokia 33 10 ou
le lg qui s'ouvre aux glissant comme ça
le mène à main c'est le cas ok donc ce
camp la main levée vous avez dans le nez
entre 18 et 34 ans ça c'est tout le
symbole c'est une forme de toute une
génération la génération y et vous est
ce que les sociologues américains vous
rappeler les millénium vous êtes aussi
la première génération avoir grandi avec
internet et ça commence à le voir ça a
tout changé
moi je m'appelle bout de six aussi un
millenium ils gênent les entreprises à
se préparer à se réinventer pour le
futur notamment en parlant de la
génération y mais aussi en parlant de
créativité parce que j'ai été comme nous
l'avons entendu magicien et créateurs
d'illusions pendant dix ans à peu près
et donc oui il y aura un peu de magie
dans cette compétition mais c'est
surtout en tant que millenium que je
suis ici aujourd'hui parce que ça me
fait mal au coeur de voir qu'un clivage
qui s'est créée qui s'agrandit entre
notre génération et les précédentes
depuis la nuit des temps audi à la
nouvelle génération les jeunes et son
pari ce fait sont gâtées ça c'est un
grand classique ça a toujours existé
mais maintenant avec internet on nous
met sur le dos des maux de la société
avec lesquels on n'a rien à voir les
choses se mélangent et c'est de ces
faits de manière publique on est un
petit peu ouvertement humilié je pense
notamment à la vidéo de simon sinek spa
qui l'a vu ici mais c'est un pou fèr
entier dont le thème a été l'un des plus
vues et dans une vidéo une interview sur
la génération y qui dit de notre
génération
donc ceux qui ont aujourd'hui entre 18
20 et 34 ans que nous sommes et je cite
une génération fragile et gâtés que nous
sommes connectés au virtuel mais
déconnecté de l'humain bon travail
jusqu'à là et donc on n'a pas de réseau
mais il dit aussi que nous avons une
éducation raté pour le coup
immédiatement vos charges que le thon
terme qu'on sait pas gérer ce stress
comme narcissique
on se drogue on se suicide et les autres
sont bloqués avec nous en entreprise bon
on pourrait se dire c'est qu'une vidéo
parmi tant d'autres pourquoi je parle
spécialement de cette vidéo
le problème c'est que j'ai comptabilisé
sur les réseaux sociaux en cumulé plus
de 200 ça veut dire que l sur un sujet
aussi spécifique c'est énorme c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est la
référence sur notre génération
du coup tout le monde s'engouffre un peu
dans cette solution de facilité
les articles sur les réseaux sociaux sur
le même ton se multiplient comme si les
y avait plus à se reprocher que les x ou
les baby boomers
alors pour ceux qui sont un peu perdus
avec sa xy etc je vous explique en deux
secondes c'est extrêmement simple dans
le sens dans ce sens ça ça fait x y z
aujourd'hui on parle des 18-34 ans j'ai
un temps y est la z c'est ce qu'ont 18
où on va pas en parler sinon ça
complique les choses
bon quand le rêve de l'équation est tout
en vous y allez baby boomers cse les
bébés d'après guerre et encore après
hélas aujourd'hui on va parler
principalement de notre génération
d'écart cas avec les générations
précédentes plus âgées pour les puristes
qui disent oui à bienne catégorie entre
deux s'appelle l'exil gnôle bon on va
pas voir on va faire plus simple on
enlève et une première chose à faire je
pense en tant que membre de la
génération y c'est 2 comprendre ces x et
ses baby boomers parce que notre notre
société la commutation particulièrement
accéléré ces 50 dernières années encore
mais qu'en plus ces trente dernières
années
avec la globalisation déjà mais
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies les
réseaux sociaux etc et nous les
millénium on a muté avec ces changements
et des sociologues d'air qui nous
appellent les mutants et c'est pas le
cas pour les x et les baby boomers sont
pas grandi avec internet
donc quand ils voient qu'il ya des
jeunes qui privilégie des des
communautés des jeux virtuels que ils
deviennent milliardaires avec des sites
internet sur des concepts un petit peu
bizarre comme snap chat ou spotify on
peut comprendre qu'à une perte de
repères qui sont un petit peu perdu mais
c'est pas pour autant
qu'on doit cautionner des critiques
ouvertes sans solution sans empathie si
on veut mieux vivre et travailler
ensemble faut qu'on se comprenne alors
comment comprendre notre génération qui
est si complexe moyenne et ce jusque est
très simple qui est déjà connu
c'est de prononcer le grec comme en
anglais one pour ce que j'avais fait
d'anglais au premier et au collège c'est
à dire pourquoi et pourquoi c'est
principalement ce que notre génération
essaie de comprendre pourquoi est ce
qu'on fait les choses de telle ou telle
manière alors que tout a changé
pourquoi de ce qu'on devrait faire ce
métier où aller dans tel voit que nos
parents ou nos profs nous on par
laquelle ils nous ont poussés
alors qu'aujourd'hui il ya plein
d'autres métiers qui sont à disposition
en fait c'est plutôt une crise de sens
dans laquelle on est on a plein
d'informations sandra aujourd'hui un
accès à l'information puisque puisque
n'importe lequel époques de l'histoire
avec notre téléphone sur google on peut
avoir accès à n'importe quelle
information mais c'est une crise de sens
qu'on traverse et je pense que même dans
les speechs qu'on a vu aujourd'hui avec
jacob ont traversé tous un petit peu
cette quête de sens moi-même comme vous
l'avez entendu je suis parti en amérique
latine pendant un peu moins d'un an
après mes études d'économie mais
pourquoi c'est parce que je me disais
pourquoi je devrais faire les métiers
qui me sont présentés le prof d'économie
au lycée ou chercheurs alors que ce
n'est pas la voie que je veux prendre je
suis parti je me suis ouvert à d'autres
choses j'ai parlé à d'autres gens j'ai
appris énormément de choses me suis posé
beaucoup la question pourquoi ceci
pourquoi cela et c'est là que j'ai
découvert ma passion pour le métier de
magicien je sais c'est un parcours un
peu particulier c'est pas le cas tout le
monde mais je ne suis pas le seul parmi
les millénium armes est en fait des
schémas en cause du chemin qui sont déjà
en place et au fond je pense que c'est
ça un petit peu qui agace les
générations précédentes que on a déjà
beaucoup de choses
faut le dire en voyage plus facilement
on a un accès à l'information des
technologies des gadgets etc au monde
encore plus on veut aller plus loin
ici on si on veut aller plus loin c'est
surtout qu'on a le luxe de pouvoir se
poser des questions
grâce à ce que vous nous avez laissé on
peut voir comment on va aller plus loin
dans notre façon de consommer de façon
de travailler
aujourd'hui on se demande pas si on va
survivre c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
mais comment va mieux vivre donc on veut
savoir où est ce que nous courgettes ont
poussé qui a fait notre tee shirt et
dans quelles conditions et on veut plus
de choses de travail et là je pense
qu'il ya un gros noeuds défaire sur
notre génération par rapport aux autres
c'est celle qui touche au monde du
travail et au nom de l'entreprise et qui
s'est développée aujourd'hui et je vous
dis ça c'est pas subjectif parce que
quand j'ai tapé sur google sans rien
avoir tapé avant j'ai tapé pourquoi
génération y qui me dit pourquoi
génération y démissionne pourquoi les
malheureuses au travail et pourquoi elle
n'est pas heureuse
y en a qui essaient de comprendre ici et
vous savez mes clients souvent des
milléniaux ce qui m'engagent ma femme et
mes amis sont des millenium beaucoup de
travail en entreprise
et quand je parle avec eux je peux vous
dire que c'est une question de sens ils
veulent savoir à quoi ils servent
comment ils impactent l'entreprise ils
ont marre de faire un job bas existe sur
le papier sonne très bien
chef de projet ceci ou cela mais qui en
fait se traduit par des longues horaires
un manager qui fait passer ses sautes
d'humeur sur nous et c'est donc
aujourd'hui la fiche de paye
malheureusement elle suffit plus on veut
plus de sens plus d'impact et je pense
que c'est pour ça aussi qui en retour à
l'auto-entreprise à l'entrepreneuriat
d'une manière générale à l'artisanat et
aux start up soit maintenant veut lancer
sa start up soit on veut travailler avec
une start up
même si ça veut dire gagner moins parce
que on va répondre à un besoin qui est
beaucoup plus claire et je sais que
parmi les générations précédentes y en a
qui sont encore indigné crise les jeunes
maintenant ils veulent s'exprimer au
travail va s'épanouir et moi ces
personnages leur dirai fait attention
quand même parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
plus dans une phase d'indignation les
statistiques montrent que d'ici 2025
génération y va représenter 70% la
population active de la plupart des pays
c'est énorme
prêts à les aides car il savait encore
une autre histoire
mais aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans une
phase d'adaptation et je pense que les
entreprises et même les autres
structures peuvent facilement apporter
aux au millennium ce qui demande
d'appareils de sens mais il suffit
simplement de les impliquer davantage
leur montrer quels impacts qu'ils ont
sur l'entreprise ne peut pas juste leur
dire fais ça et c'est bon tu te tais on
demande aussi des responsabilités mais
ça c'est comme toutes les générations ça
se fait petit à petit au compte gouttes
avec la confiance et plus de flexibilité
et ça on demande aujourd'hui à
travailler davantage en télétravail où
on voudrait et ça c'est pas forcément
évident de comprendre ça de la part des
x et des baby boomers
une chose est sûre c'est que les
entreprises qui apporte sa génération y
ils vont cartonner ça c'est sûr on le
voit déjà celles qui le font et ceux qui
les bloque
ça va poser problème et un individu
quand il est dans une quête de
sensations lui dit et au à nous ça fait
20 ans qu'on fait ça a toujours fait
comme ça donc c'est sûr que ebay ebay
est malheureux au travail ou à
démissionner tout de suite donc moi je
vous propose quelque chose c'est de
réouvrir le dialogue entre nos deux
générations de se réconcilier et on
qu'on fasse la paix déjà tout simplement
mais pour ça il ya rien de mieux que de
briser la glace avec un petit peu de
magie enfin donc je leur besoin d'une
qui a la cinquantaine a levé la main ce
que ceux qui ont la cinquantaine levé la
main pour beaucoup
tenez monsieur voulait bien me rejoindre
sur scène on peut l'applaudir bien fort
[Musique]
et pendant que vous nous rejoignez vous
appelez comment philippe venet dans le
rouge serait bienvenue je vais donner ce
dictionnaire un millenium j'en ai pleuré
au premier rang je sais ce que c'est
c'est comme wikipedia mais en moins
complet en plus fiables voilà et
philippe djian un roman un apéro féminin
ce que vous l'avez déjà lu non alors
c'est vous pouvez checker que ce soit
pas voilà que je vous laisse feuilleter
les pages
mais en attendant vous appelez baptiste
vous allez d'abord on n'a rien arrangé
tous les trois vous connaissez pas on se
connaît pas ok ce qu'on va essayer de
faire c'est que déjà vous allez penser à
un chiffre entre 1 et 129 parce que
c'est le nombre de pages qu'il ya dans
ce livre d'accord pour penser à un
chiffre entre soit 9 c'est bon vous avez
checker leulier bien rien de particulier
ok est-ce que vous pouvez lui dire la
page à laquelle il va ouvrir le livre
allez on va collaborer sur moi je vais
vous montrer qu'au beau travailler tous
ensemble on peut collaborer ensemble les
hittites les lieux c'est vous qui allez
décider la page d'accueil de nouveau
l'épreuve je regarde est ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'à la page 42 en attendant
qu'ils fassent tout ça vous pouvez le
chic et le dictionnaire aussi
c'est intéressant comme beaucoup ce que
vous allez faire c'est que vous allez
prendre à la page 42 un mot celui que
vous voulez mais assez conséquent me
montrait pas mais tu es bien le voilà
les libéraux et on va essayer de créer
une connexion entre nous deux de voir si
je peux à lire dans vos pensées donc
vous allez m'aider vous avez m'envoyer
les mots psychologiquement et vous allez
prendre un mot qui est pas trop facile à
deviner dans le là parce que des
probabilités que je devine un mois ses
conséquences si cette lettre vous
regardez un et si vous voulez changer
vous pouvez prendre un autre allez-y
c'est bon on a bien ok moi tellement me
dit t'as rien bouger pas les lèvres pour
la première fois est ce que l'être à
laquelle vous pensez t1 p la première
lettre du monde voulait que ce soit pas
filmé c'était pas un bébé c'était quoi
un b au cas me dit rien d'autre ne dit
rien de bon de façon je me suis engagé
avec un impayé donc on va on va
continuer comme ça vous savez quoi
moi je vais je vais aller avec ma
première intuition ça pourra me donner
une deuxième chance nous donner une
deuxième chance
ils sont sympas c'est carrément des
besoins ok 1 b un bo bien me dit rien
d'autre savez quoi envoyer ma les
lettres une par une vraiment connectez
vous à moi me dit pas bougé pas vos
lèvres me dit rien on voyait mal être
on n'a rien arrangé
est ce que pour apprendre fois pouvait
dire va autrement auquel vous pensez
bien fait tort moi aussi vous savez quoi
ok tout à l'heure j'ai marqué paix mais
je reste quand même avec ma première
intuition
parce que ce que j'avais marqué le pas
sur ma première intuition c'était p 81
des 5 b ça vous dit rien non parce
qu'estimant est ce que pouvait ouvrir le
dictionnaire souplet page 81 et on va
essayer de regarder sur la colonne de
droite
la page 81 colonne de droite est le
cinquième but en partant du bas et vous
dites avoir au très fort qu'est le
cinquième au partant du bas page 81
colonne de droite
jeff et heures on peut les applaudir
bien fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant on s'est bien amusé et qu'on
a brisé la glace
moi je vous propose quelque chose de
simple c'est qu'on commence à s'écouter
les uns les autres pour voir ce qu'on a
à offrir
de chaque côté notre génération y a à
offrir
la maîtrise des outils digitaux
tiendrait capacité d'adaptation
extraordinaire ça c'est une compétence
très recherchée aujourd'hui et si pour
les plus âgés vous écouter ce qu'on a à
dire sur le marché du travail il ya
beaucoup de choses que vous pourriez
apprendre notamment le comporte des
comportements des consommateurs les
grandes tendances d'authenticité à
transparence et c est évidemment la
connaissance et l'importance des réseaux
sociaux
même moi qu'à 30 ans je fais appel à des
plus jeunes aujourd'hui pour qui même là
dessus et plus vous allez les écouter
plus eux seront en temps à écouter ce
que vous avez à transmettre parce que je
pense qu'il faut pas se leurrer oui on a
une bonne capacité d'adaptation mais
aujourd'hui plus que jamais dans un
monde qui change autant on a besoin
aussi de guide de mentors quand un
animal tout à l'heure plus âgés qui
peuvent nous transmettre leur expérience
donc pour les y sont dans la salle où
même les aides ce qu'ils soient remises
en train de regarder ne négligez pas
tous cas mentor peut vous apporter eux
sont passés par des phases de vie
personnelle professionnelle qui sont
encore devant vous et quand vous êtes un
petit peu frustré un patient sur
certaines choses qui peuvent vous
rassurer sur le futur quand vous êtes un
peu bloqué peut vous aider à aller plus
loin et ça peut être un prof ou dans
votre établissement un parent un oncle
un ami en dehors dans le sport la
musique
peu importe en fait moi par exemple
c'est dans le judo du jeu mais premier
mentor donc j'ai ce que ce par quoi j'ai
commencé mais quand j'étudiais la magie
quand j'avais 20 23 ans c'est moi qui me
suis bougé pour aller chercher des
magiciens plus expérimentés j'ai été
étudié aux états unis à mes propres
frais mais certains de ces magiciens
légendaire sont devenus mes mentors et
m'ont aidée non seulement développé de
magie mais aussi m'ont transmis des
leçons de vie qui était unique
j'aurais pu trouver nulle part ailleurs
et moi aussi aider à rediriger vers une
voix qui me convenait mieux suite j'ai
un mentor pour mon premier livre pour
mon deuxième livre en tant que comédien
j'ai plein de mentor mais une chose est
sûre c'est que je serai pas dû
là où j'en suis aujourd'hui sans eux
donc au final ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est que on a autant besoin des
générations précédentes qu'ils ont
besoin de nous moi ce que je vous
propose à tous c'est qu'on fasse un pas
l'un vers l'autre
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
laisse avec une citation de martin
luther king qui dit nous devons
apprendre à vivre ensemble comme des
frères
si nous allons mourir ensemble comme des
idiots merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]